and finally today again folks i am so
sorry we are running out of time but i
do have one more thing i want to talk
about here and that is south dakota
governor christie
gnome
christy gnome
an ethics board this week in south
dakota
said that it's likely
likely they said
that she engaged in misconduct
with regard to her daughter's real
estate appraiser's license
this is a weird weird story
because it also involves a republican
attorney general who had to uh resign in
disgrace
after he ran over somebody
but this republican attorney general at
one point was hot on gnomes trail
working on this case you know and
tilly pretty much killed somebody and
had to leave office it's not funny that
somebody died it's just funny that these
republicans in south dakota are so
screwed up
but anyway
what had happened
was that christie gnome's daughter a
couple years ago uh was at cassidy
peters
wanted to become a real estate appraiser
but you gotta have a license in south
dakota to do that
so she applies she takes the tests all
of this and they look at it and they say
nah you can't have your real estate
appraiser's license
but mommy was the governor
so
what christy gnome did was she called a
meeting
and she called a meeting
with the state employee who ran the
agency that gives those licenses the
woman's direct supervisor and the state
labor secretary
and for some reason even though she's
not a part of the government cassidy
peters gnome's daughter was also
involved in that meeting
four months after that meeting magically
christy gnome's daughter
gets that real estate license or real
estate appraiser's license
and then they also fired
the individual
who had originally denied her the
license
we do not know
i mean
we don't know for certain
what happened in that meeting we
obviously see the outcomes the person
who denied the license loses her job
they then pay her 200 000 to not file a
discrimination suit against them and
cassidy peters gets her real estate
appraiser's license everybody goes home
happy right
and so this ethics board in south dakota
says we think you know it's likely
that she engaged in misconduct likely
the issue is not over but unfortunately
we are out of time but i think i got a
lot that we know so far but anyway thank
you so much for tuning in we got a great
bonus show coming up for everybody
including rick scott leaving the country
right as uh republicans want answers
about where all their money went i am
farron cousins i've been in for david
pakman you can find me at youtube.com
the ring of fire
youtube.com fair and balanced twitter
facebook instagram at fair and balanced
this is the david pakman show
thanks for watching